batarli klitschko first made his name as
a champion boxer he turned to politics
in 2005
and became the mayor of the ukrainian
capital kiev in 2014 but he never
imagined he'd be defending his city and
his people from an invasion by the
russian military a little earlier i
spoke to vitaly klitschko the mayor of
kiev
vitale first up thank you so much for
sparing some time to talk to us when you
are in the middle of what you're in
let me start with the military situation
now in kiev putin has advanced on the
city but he's failed to capture it
and nor has he at the moment sought to
flatten it
with shelling and moscow's now saying it
doesn't want to put keeve at military
risk
are we at a stage yet where you feel you
could say that kiev is safe
first of all it's
nobody feel him
safe
in ukraine
if you in ukraine are you sorry in
danger second point uh right now the
huge battle we're talking right now and
listen it's uh explosion
explosion uh it's battle right now north
of the city and east of the city so you
can hear that yeah
outside
yeah i hear right now outside this
explosion
explosion because in uh
uh
erpina
baradyanka gastown
uh right now right now there is fighting
it's
near to bravarry it's a small city
satellite city of
kiev
and that's why right now that circle
around
the the the
russian russian uh army we moved back
and uh they moved
uh but uh still danger and we listen
all day the explosions fatally when the
russians say then that they tell us and
we hear these press conferences where
they say that they are switching
attention away from keeve
and they are moving their forces
elsewhere
you don't see evidence of that you don't
believe that's what they're doing
please don't believe russians
this will be biggest mistake
uh they told it's not we are in the next
luges was not true
they told they don't want to work
against ukraine it's not rude right now
right now the occupation of ukraine the
russian
russian forces
make
war it's not rude right now it's
russians told they go away
it's not true the battle is there maybe
some part of um
forces move to another
side of ukraine but they still around
kiev and vitaly i think we've got some
pictures i want to show you some
pictures that we've been seeing here in
the uk i don't know if you can see them
we have one of mario paul this is mario
paul this is from a drone
and then we also have some pictures from
urpin which is not that far
from you when you see these pictures how
does it make you feel
it's
it's painful to see these pictures the
city doesn't exist anymore
the whole uh
building is destroyed the city is
destroyed and uh it was a couple of
months ago it's a great part of our
cities where
uh very comfortable life and
it was
privileged to live in a
satellite city to near to kiev right now
the the city not exist anymore right now
we're collecting their their bodies the
people who
are killed from russians
when you when you see those pictures of
of of other parts of ukraine
are you fearful that this could happen
to kiev or do you think that the
russians would not dare
to bomb the capital in that way
i have a feeling
i have a feeling the russians doesn't
have
some
some
moral protection or i don't know it's
they killing civilians
they
kill children
woman's they destroyed marijuana
destroyed more than 50 percent of
buildings in harkid totally destroyed
its apartments building
they destroyed help of
turning if it's
150 kilometers around 100 miles from
kiev and
i guess they can't use any
weapons we
talking right now
about the chemical weapons the russians
already use that in syria
and uh
eve couple of months ago
somebody tell me is
what i think about the war i will be
i i never expect
in the modern time
in europe
we have a
huge war
this war is biggest one after the second
world war
and uh
if couple of months ago i tell it's
impossible but right now
right now
right now if you if you ask about our
hometown
it's everything possible if we look on
marieuple in hurricane
just on on life in kiev at the moment
it's hard for us to understand what it's
like there because what we see
is the reports focused on war can you
describe what it's like in kiev at the
moment are you able to go to shops are
cafes open kids go into schools how are
you living at the moment
before the the before the war
just two months ago uh one half months
ago the population
of
our city
uh what three and a half million people
we are one of the largest uh city in
east
uh europe
uh right now we guesses
health population as uh women's children
already left
the majority right now the mans who
ready to defend our city yeah uh
the life
we it's actually is war destroyed the
logistics war destroyed the normal life
in the people
and
right now the
streets is empty it's uh
blog post with web with people
with uniform
with weapons spiritual defense
but
slowly uh listen uh ukrainian listen uh
the russian forces a little bit far from
keith
but everybody want to get we want to
come
back to city
it's personal
it's
i talk to many people everybody won't
come to bed but it's personal decision
of every family is for everyone
but
the it's personal risk for everyone who
come to kiev we see we have a release an
explosion uh
every day
and uh the risk
to diet is pretty high and that's why my
personal advice for everyone
who want to come please
take a little bit more time
let's see how
situation will be developed in the next
couple of weeks and vitaly your family
you have children you've got three
children
do you see them or have you had to send
them away i mean presumably you
are at risk personally because the
russians have you on their hit list
the minor brothers to give vladimir is
together with me yeah uh
it's uh
i send my mom and vladimir and his
daughter outside of the country it's
right now this uh family it's outside of
the country so you haven't seen
you haven't seen your family for weeks
more than months
that's really hard that's really hard
um
you are on the russia hit list
president zielenski we know about
assassination attempts on him have there
been assassination attempts on you
it's everyone in ukraine
in danger
everyone every citizens of ukraine right
now in ukraine uh her risk
uh
i come from a military family my father
former officer
uh he's actually died
and spent his life to defend the people
in ukraine in
by chernobyl
nuclear
catastrophe what ukraine have 1986
uh father study me and my brother is big
privilege
i am former soldier also
it's big privilege for every man
to give his life
as defender of your country
and that's why we are not afraid nobody
wants to die
but
it's our home
it's our hometown
it's our families it's our children we
defend our children we defend the future
we don't want to live in the country in
in soviet union we don't want back to
ussr we don't want to live in the
country
with no human rights waste no
press freedom
waste no rules i talking about the
russian federation because they put in
the goal of putin to rebuild russian
empire and uh to occupate ukraine and
to rebuild soviet union
we was in susa and we don't back in the
past time and vitali you are clearly
prepared to die for your country i think
you're saying to me if you lose your
life
you are not afraid
nobody wants to die
nobody wants to die
i tell you some example
i uh
praying the
everyday i go to
every districts of our city i stumbled
about blog post and civil defense i am
very surprised the people with very
peaceful profession
for example musicians
actors
doctors
right now
they stay with uniform they never they
never expect
to take the weapons in the hands but
right now they want to defend his city
hometown
and
we
we always was peaceful nation
is we ukraine is peaceful country we
never was aggressive to anyone but right
now
is the question about our future future
of our children
we have to defend vitali can i ask you
just quickly about your future
putin clearly wants to take the donbass
region and some of the south of the
country
could you live with russia taking some
territory from ukraine in order for
peace
russians right now starting to talk
about
some compromise
what about we talk
i don't know
compromise to give the russians
some part of our territory his
compromise his job
the compromise if the russians killed
thousands of ukrainians and right now we
have to find the solution i don't know
what
we talk about what we what we have to
talk about
and that why
that way just one wish
russians go away russian soldiers have
to go away from our home country
and after that we're ready to discuss
we understand the russian
army much stronger than ukrainian is
actually ukrainian soldier ukrainian
army destroyed
meters
about
strongest russian strongest army in the
world
i explain why
ukrainians are tough because russian
soldiers paid their fighting for the
money
ukrainian soldiers ukrainian citizens
fighting for the future of our children
are you feel the difference between the
money
and the children
and vitaly i have one final question for
you then you're clear that you are not
going to
let putin take any ukraine territory
what about president selensky's
suggestion
that ukraine could perhaps
have a compromise at committing to
neutrality and maybe putting that to a
referendum to the people is that
something as the leader of the capital
you could live with
uh first of all i am not involved in
negotiation process between ukraine and
russia
[Music]
the final document uh
that's why we don't know what we talked
about i i'm i'm not ready to give the
commenter about that
uh and uh
also the referendum uh natural status we
was always natural country
we want to be the part of european
family it's our decision
we want to be democratic modern country
it's our decision
and to take away our wish
it's not fair it's we decide and we have
we need to be
someone who would take a decision
regarding regarding negotiation and
referendum i don't know how we make the
referendum in in the war
big part of ukrainian right now outside
of the country they
moved
uh they to safety place
uh in during the war we have a lot of
questions and not so many answers for
that
by the way
i'm
let's see the negotiation
document the
let's see
negotiation
letters what uh
what
make here
both sides enough that we can discuss
about that okay vitaly klitschko thank
you so much for spending some time to
talk to us tonight thank you
thank you